pas facile d'avoir 20 ans face à cette
situation sanitaire que nous connaissons
tous depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
alors comment ces jeunes vivent t-il
cette époque si particulière rencontre
ce midi avec christelle une jeune maman
dijonnaise bombe à gueye et tiphaine
fighter
c'est dieu c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir
un temps en 2001 c'est tout
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle christelle ngoma
vivent deux ans et je suis maman d'un
petit garçon de deux ans qui s'appelle
méthode j'ai eu une grossesse très très
difficile du début jusqu'à la fin j'ai
été malade tout le temps j'avais des
problèmes pour m'alimenter et tout donc
il fallait aller deux fois par semaine
dans le mois au chu où elle était
hospitalisée
il est content d'aller à la crèche au
moins là-bas il joue avec ses copains et
puis voilà
voilà pourquoi la crps et c'est bien ça
permet de se libérer
quand il est à la crèche là t'as pas
d'enfant tu peux prendre le bus a pas de
poussée est fait on y va je peux
t'asseoir tranquillement tu prends un
thé ou un café et une grignote tu fais
ta vie quoi quand il est à la crèche là
tu es plus maman tu te re devient maman
c'est quand tu vas le chercher à 17h
lactée maman ça fait trois ans que j'ai
pas changer mon téléphone avant
d'acheter quelque chose je me rends
compte du prix le coût de la vie en fait
à changer je ne me permet plus à faire
des folies de grandeur
quand on est maman devient responsable
de soi même et de l'enfant qu'on a eu à
apporter du coup tout ce qu'on fait
c'est en fonction de l'enfant ça ne m'a
jamais posé un problème d'être maman
c'est vrai il ya eu beaucoup de choses
que j'ai mis de côté mais je regrette
pas j'ai fait un enfant certes mais j'ai
le droit d'être heureuse
aux comores
un étudiant 120 sacs scellés tanger
d'hier et celles et les tentes en mai
sonne il les connaît tellement bien que
quand il vient dans la maison y passe le
temps son envie de jouer avec mason
j'ai toujours mes habitudes que je peux
sortir comme cet enfant les autres en
fait que je perds pas le côté les jeunes
parce que j'ai un enfant
donc quand je savais que je me sens pas
mal ou pas du tout elle et moi on peut
pas faire même des joues sont simples et
c'est impossible
pour qu'on s'appelle même si j'ai pas le
temps même si elle n'a pas le temps au
moins pour savoir ce qui se passe et moi
je regarde pas forcément de ce côté
maman moi j'ai surtout la personne en
soit on apprend beaucoup de choses avec
la pompe que jenson button
traiter les gens j'attends de commencer
une formation d'ici le mois de mai deux
secteurs médical donc je préfère rester
dans le côté médical parce que j'ai déjà
eu à travailler avec des personnes âgées
en crèche une école maternelle
[Musique]
y'a pas un parent qui cède que sa fille
tombe enceinte à 19 ans en sachant que
tu as un parcours scolaire et tout ça si
tu avais pas prouvé être enceinte et que
ces arrivées ben faut déjà accepté ça
que voilà je suis tombée enceinte qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire
avoir confiance en soi et se dire que
voilà
avoir un enfant c'est pas la fin du
monde d'avoir un enfant savait pas dire
que j'ai raté ma vie où je les ai échoué
non bien au contraire
vous avez un enfant donnez-vous les
efforts possibles
soyez bien entouré afin de continuer le
parcours de la vie
[Musique]